Magie divine,
le monde du surnaturel.
En l'an 1791,
les habitants de Salon de Provence
décident de
transférer les ossements
du plus célèbre
personnage de la ville
dans un lieu plus approprié.
Plus de
200 ans auparavant,
on l'avait enterré
comme il le souhaitait,
debout,
sous le maître autel
de la petite église des
Cordeliers, dans le centre ville.
Cette exhumation
suscite la curiosité générale.
Après tout,
il ne s'agit pas
de la dépouille
d'un homme comme les autres
et les récits vantant
ses pouvoirs magiques
ont fait
le tour de l'Europe.
On dit qu'il était
capable de voir l'avenir.
Autour de son cou,
on trouve une amulette
sur laquelle
est gravé le chiffre 1791,
c'est-à-dire l'année
même de son exhumation.
Cet homme s'appelle
Michel de Nostredame.
Plus connu sous
le nom de Nostradamus.
Il aurait prédit, entre autres,
l'arrivée d'Hitler au pouvoir,
l'assassinat de Kennedy
et la Révolution française.
Né en 1503, il fut le plus
célèbre prophète du XVIᵉ siècle.
La période de l'âge d'or
de la prophétie occidentale.
Prophétie.
Le monde est
dangereux et incertain.
Combien de fois sommes-nous
manipulés par des puissances
qui échappent
à notre contrôle.
Même si certains essaient
de savoir ce que réserve l'avenir,
la plupart d'entre
nous se résigne à l'ignorer.
En nous révélant
de quoi demain sera fait,
les prophètes et les devins
nous sauvent de l'incertitude.
Ils voient
dans le présent
non seulement
des traces du passé,
mais aussi
des signes de l'avenir.
Mais dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui,
l'art divinatoire
a aussi mauvaise réputation
que les autres
sciences occultes,
magie,
alchimie ou astrologie.
Qui est-ce ?
He is having
his fortune toId.
La divination est
considérée comme marginale,
quand elle n'est pas
totalement rejetée.
Do not swim
in the ocean,
that would be fatal.
Pourtant, la divination
existe depuis la nuit des temps.
Et dans les grandes
civilisations antiques,
elle a joué un rôle essentiel
dans la vie des Hommes.
Son influence
ne fût jamais aussi forte
que dans la
Grèce antique.
La Grèce
a bâti sa grandeur
sur les fondations
des cultures primitives,
dont elle a conservé
de nombreuses traces.
D'abord et surtout,
les Grecs ont hérité
de leurs ancêtres
une croyance
aveugle en la prophétie.
Les prophéties les
plus sacrées sont les oracles.
Les prédictions faites
par les divinités elles-mêmes,
dans un sanctuaire.
Le plus célèbre
de ces sanctuaires
est le grand
temple d'Apollon, à Delphes.
Ce sanctuaire construit
sur les pentes du mont Parnasse,
recevra pendant
près de 1000 ans
de nombreux visiteurs
venus non seulement de Grèce,
mais de
tout le monde antique.
Le personnage central
de l'opération est la Pythie.
C'est un médium,
mais qui n'agit pas
par elle-même.
Ce sont les dieux
qui s'expriment par sa bouche.
Avant de pouvoir
interroger Apollon,
il y a tout
un rituel complexe.
La Pythie se purifie
et entame un travail
qui l'amène dans
une sorte de transe.
Puis elle crie.
On ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'elle dit
ni comment
cela sort de sa bouche,
Mais ces cris sont ensuite
interprétés par un prêtre.
Puis il les traduit
en vers hexamètres.
Consignés par écrit,
ces vers constituent
la réponse à la question posée.
Lorsque la civilisation grecque
s'étend à d'autres territoires,
Delphes devient alors
une étape obligée
sur le chemin de la
guerre et de la conquête.
Mais les oracles
sont souvent trompeurs.
Un grand roi, Crésus,
demande un jour à l'oracle
s'il doit attaquer
l'Empire perse.
L'oracle lui répond
que s'il part en guerre,
il détruira
un grand royaume.
Encouragé
par cette prophétie,
Crésus se lance
dans la bataille.
Son armée subit alors
une cuisante défaite
et le grand
royaume qu'il détruit
n'est autre que le sien.
Mais il est un désastre
que Delphes n'a pas su prévoir,
sa propre décadence.
Avec la montée
du christianisme,
on voit émerger la croyance
en un Créateur tout puissant
qui préside à la
destinée de l'humanité entière.
Les prophètes comme
Abraham, Moïse et Jésus-Christ
vont révéler
cette vision au monde
et leur message est puissant.
Si tu obéis à Dieu,
l'avenir t'appartiendra.
Mais si tu ignores sa parole,
les conséquences seront terribles.
Dans les siècles
qui suivent la mort de Jésus,
le christianisme
se répand dans le monde entier
et la tradition des
prophètes chrétiens se perpétue.
Dans l'Europe du XVIᵉ siècle,
l'influence de ces
prophètes atteint son apogée.
Cette époque
est également marquée
par la renaissance
des arts antiques.
Alchimie, magie et astrologie
se mêlent alors
à la tradition chrétienne.
Nul n'incarne mieux
ces diverses influences
que Michel de Nostredame.
Michel de Nostredame
ne commencera à écrire
les prophéties
qui l'ont rendu si célèbre
que vers l'âge de 50 ans.
Mais déjà, jeune homme,
il se fait connaître en
combattant l'un des pires fléaux
qui se soit abattu sur
l'Europe depuis un millénaire,
la peste.
La peste bubonique
se répand sur tout le continent,
semant la misère
et la mort sur son passage.
Plus du tiers de la population
européenne y succombera.
Les gens sont sans défense.
Ni les prières ni la médecine
ne parviennent
à enrayer l'épidémie.
À 26 ans, Michel
de Nostredame devient médecin
et, selon
l'usage de l'époque,
latinise son nom
et se fait appeler Nostradamus.
Il passe ensuite
plusieurs années à voyager,
en Provence
et partout où sévit la peste.
Son approche de
la maladie est inhabituelle,
tout comme sa thérapeutique.
Il ne croit pas
aux vertus des saignées.
Il prescrit des remèdes
dont l'efficacité ne sera reconnue
que bien
des années après sa mort.
Ce qui est
vraiment intéressant,
c'est que Nostradamus
ordonne à ses patients
de respecter des règles
d'hygiènes élémentaires.
Or, nul ne peut
lui avoir enseigné cela
puisqu'à l'époque
on ne possède en Europe
aucune connaissance
dans ce domaine.
Alors qu'on ignore encore
que le manque d'hygiène
peut provoquer des maladies,
il insiste
pour que ses patients
dorment dans
des draps propres,
respirent le grand air
et fassent de l'exercice.
Grâce à ces conseils,
il réussit là où
les autres médecins échouent.
Bientôt on parle
de lui dans toute l'Europe
et plusieurs villes
l'appellent à la rescousse.
Malheureusement,
ses talents de guérisseur
ne suffisent pas à sauver
sa propre femme
et son enfant.
Ils succombent
à cette terrible maladie.
Aujourd'hui, il est
difficile de s'imaginer
les souffrances
qu'enduraient les pestiférés.
Mais à l'époque,
cette maladie est
synonyme d'horreur absolue.
Et l'on voit dans les
ravages causés par la peste,
l'expression
de la colère divine.
Nostradamus
va partout où la mort frappe.
Quel péché
les Hommes ont-ils commis ?
Quel est le message
que Dieu veut leur transmettre ?
Sans doute Nostradamus
s'est-il posé ces questions
et a-t-il tenté d'y répondre
en interprétant les signes.
Alors qu'il officie
comme médecin ambulant,
ce praticien
aux idées avancées
vit une expérience qui
éveille sa vocation de prophète.
Aux environs
d'Ancône, en Italie,
il croise
deux moines sur sa route.
Comme on lui
demande ce qu'il fait,
Nostradamus
se contente de répondre :
« Je dois m'agenouiller
devant Sa Sainteté ».
L'un des deux moines,
le frère Felice Peretti,
n'est encore
qu'un novice à l'époque.
Mais 19 ans plus tard,
il deviendra pape.
En 1547,
à l'âge de 44 ans,
Nostradamus se remarie
et s'installe dans une nouvelle
demeure et une nouvelle vie.
Il transforme
son grenier en études
et commence
à rédiger des prophéties.
À mon sens
ce changement
ne marque pas une rupture
avec sa formation initiale,
mais au contraire,
une continuité.
Car à l'époque,
l'astrologie occupait
une part très importante
dans les études de médecine.
L'astrologie est fondée
sur la croyance
selon laquelle les mouvements
et les cycles
des corps célestes
exercent une influence
sur la vie terrestre.
Pour décrire les effets
produits sur la Terre par le Soleil,
la Lune
et les différentes planètes,
les astrologues
développent une théorie complexe.
Selon cette théorie,
l'examen de la carte du ciel
pour une période à venir,
c'est-à-dire
l'étude d'un horoscope,
permet de déterminer
quelles influences astrales
s'exerceront
à un moment précis.
C'est ainsi que l'astrologie
devient un art divinatoire.
Au XVIᵉ siècle,
la plupart des sciences
se réfèrent à l'astrologie.
Y compris la médecine.
En astrologie, on associe
différents systèmes
planétaires et corps célestes
à des parties
du corps humain.
De la même manière,
certaines herbes
médicinales et certains remèdes
sont liés à des configurations
planétaires précises.
Ainsi, l'astrologie permet
à la fois d'établir un diagnostic
et de prescrire un traitement.
Mais cette science
est avant tout divinatoire,
ce qui signifie que les
astrologues sont aussi des devins.
D'une certaine manière,
on peut dire que les études
de médecine de Nostradamus
l'ont préparé à
sa future carrière de prophète.
Mais la prophétie
et l'astrologie
sont deux
choses bien distinctes.
À la différence des astrologues
dont les prédictions
sont fondées sur une théorie,
les prophètes prétendent être
en relation directe avec l'avenir.
La prophétie, ainsi que
Nostradamus l'établit dans ses écrits,
est une forme de révélation.
« Seuls ceux qui possèdent
l'inspiration divine
peuvent prédire
des événements particuliers,
car eux seuls
sont de véritables prophètes. »
La clé de ce lien
que Nostradamus prétend
avoir avec la puissance divine
se trouve peut-être
dans ses origines.
Quoique de religion chrétienne,
Nostradamus
est d'origine juive
de par ses grands parents
paternels et maternels.
Ces derniers avaient
été forcés de se convertir
car à l'époque le judaïsme
était assez mal considéré.
On sait également qu'il a étudié
avec son grand père maternel.
Et ses écrits, surtout ceux
traitant de sa propre vie
et de ses
pratiques occultes,
suggèrent qu'entre autres choses,
il aurait étudié la Kabbale.
La Kabbale est
une tradition orale juive
reposant sur une interprétation
mystique et allégorique
de l'Ancien Testament,
censée détenir la clé
des mystères de l'Univers.
Les kabbalistes croient que Dieu
a laissé en chaque être humain
une partie
du secret de la Création.
C'est un peu
comme si chacun d'entre nous
était porteur
d'un fragment d'ADN universel.
Le but suprême
du kabbaliste
est de découvrir les révélations
divines qui habitent son âme.
Les rituels kabbalistiques
comprennent
la répétition de mots hébreux,
particulièrement des
différents noms désignant Dieu.
Noms auxquels on prête
des pouvoirs surnaturels.
Au cœur de cette science
se trouve l'Arbre de Vie.
Une représentation
de l'ordre de la Création
servant de
support à la méditation.
Les rituels ont pour but
d'atteindre un niveau
de conscience supérieur
qui permet aux kabbalistes
de dépasser le monde sensoriel.
Ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là
qu'il peut toucher au but suprême,
entrer directement
en contact avec Dieu.
Une fois parvenus à ce stade,
les kabbalistes
affirment être libérés
des contraintes temporelles.
Ils peuvent alors
formuler des prophéties
et évoluer
dans le présent éternel,
un instant
où le temps est aboli.
Les écrits
de Nostradamus
suggèrent qu'il aurait lui même atteint
des états similaires
grâce à ces rituels.
« En présence de la grâce
et du pouvoir divin,
le présent et l'avenir
ne forment plus qu'un.
C'est l'éternité là
où tout est dévoilé, limpide. »
Imaginons
maintenant Nostradamus
assis dans une pièce
plongée dans la semi-obscurité.
Une semi-obscurité
qui a sa raison d'être,
car le prophète est
contraint de pratiquer son art,
un art très
dangereux, en cachette.
À l'époque,
en effet,
les inquisiteurs traquent
les sorciers en tout genre.
Et même Nostradamus,
s'il était découvert,
ne pourrait pas
jouer de sa notoriété
pour éviter
la condamnation à mort.
Il officie donc dans le plus
grand secret et en silence.
Et nous savons par exemple
qu'il accomplit ses rituels
à l'aide
d'un bol d'eau,
d'un tripode en airain
et sans doute aussi
de plantes narcotiques
qu'il a appris à connaître
lors de ses études de médecine
et qu'il fait brûler
comme de l'encens.
« Estant assis
de nuit secret estude,
Seul repousé
sur la selle d'ærain,
Flambe exigue
sortant de solitude,
Fait proferer
qui n'est à croire vain. »
La verge en main
mise au milieu de Branches
De l'onde il moulle
& le limbe & le pied,
Un peur & voix
frémissent par les manches,
Splendeur divine.
Le devin, prés s'assied. »
Il est très
difficile aujourd'hui
de se faire une idée
des mentalités de l'époque.
De nos jours, lorsque
l'on va à l'église le dimanche,
on entend
parler de Dieu.
Mais Nostradamus, lui,
ne se contente pas de faire
de vagues discours sur Dieu.
Il voit Dieu.
Cette chose était là, devant lui,
venait à sa rencontre,
s'asseyait
tout près de lui
et surtout lui prédisait
l'avenir de l'humanité,
lui dictait
des prophéties.
En 1555, Nostradamus
publie un recueil de prophéties
intitulé
Centuries astrologiques,
qui se compose
de quatrains.
L'un des textes prédit notamment
la mort du roi de France Henri II.
Cette prophétie vaudra
à son auteur la célébrité.
« Le lion jeune,
le vieux surmontera
En champ bellique
par singulier duel,
Dans cage d'or
les yeux lui crèvera,
Deux plaies une,
pour mourir, mort cruelle. »
Un an après
la publication de ce livre,
le roi Henri II participe à un
tournoi dans les environs de Paris.
Il est opposé
au comte Montgommery,
beaucoup
plus jeune que lui.
Ils joutent un moment
et se portent
quelques coups sans gravité.
Puis la catastrophe
se produit.
La lance
de Montgomery,
en heurtant l'armure
du Roi, se brise en deux.
L'un des morceaux
transperce la gorge du Roi
et l'autre traverse
son heaume qui était en or,
lui crevant l'œil
et pénétrant dans son cerveau.
Son agonie
dure dix jours entiers.
Puis il finit par
succomber à ses blessures.
Ainsi nous retrouvons le vieux
lion décrit par Nostradamus
sur le bouclier de Henry.
Étrangement,
cet animal est également
l'emblème
du comte Montgomery,
qui n'est autre que le lion
jeune de la prédiction.
« Le lion jeune,
le vieux surmontera. »
La prédiction parle
de champ bellique,
c'est le terrain
où se déroule le tournoi.
« En champ bellique,
par singulier duel. »
On retrouve
également la cage d'or,
c'est-à-dire le heaume.
« Dans cage d'or,
les yeux lui crèvera. »
Et le Roi s'est fait
deux blessures en une
puisqu'il est touché
à la gorge et à l'œil.
« Deux plaies,
une pour mourir mort cruelle. »
Et ensuite vient
la longue agonie,
la mort cruelle
évoquée par Nostradamus.
- Même les
plus sceptiques
auraient du mal à considérer
ces troublantes concordances
comme de
simples coïncidences.
Mais très peu
de prophéties
sont aussi faciles à interpréter
que celle de la mort d'Henri II.
Ceux qui affirment
que telle ou telle prophétie
annonce la crise des missiles
cubains, la conquête de l'espace
ou la chute
de l'Empire soviétique
sont un peu
comme ces vieillards
qui cherchent
à lire dans les flammes.
Ils projettent tout
et n'importe quoi dans ces visions
et les quatrains
qu'ils cherchent à interpréter
sont suffisamment ambigus,
nébuleux et complexes
pour appuyer leurs dires.
Néanmoins, il subsiste
des exemples frappants
et difficiles à ignorer
qui poussent
encore certains
à étudier les
quatrains de Nostradamus.
L'un d'entre eux
porte sur un événement
qui s'est déroulé près de 250 ans
après la mort du prophète.
Lorsque la Révolution
française éclate en 1789,
Louis XVI et Marie-Antoinette
sont roi et reine de France.
Louis XVI
et Marie-Antoinette,
après avoir tenté en vain
de conclure un arrangement
avec les révolutionnaires,
apprennent que
leur tête est mise à prix
et tentent
de s'échapper,
mais ils échouent.
En premier lieu, je suppose,
à cause de la bêtise du Roi
qui refuse de considérer
la gravité de la situation.
Alors qu'ils tentent de gagner
Varennes par un chemin détourné,
ils sont
reconnus et arrêtés.
« De nuit viendra
par la forêt de Reines,
Deux pars vaultorte
Herne la pierre blanche,
Le moine noir
en gris dedans Varennes. »
Le plus surprenant
dans ce quatrain
est l'évocation
d'un souverain élu.
Il faut en effet se souvenir
que Louis XVI a été renversé
pendant
la Révolution française,
puis élu roi des Français
par les révolutionnaires.
Alors qu'à l'origine il est,
comme tous les rois de France,
un souverain
de droit divin,
il devient
le premier monarque élu.
« Esleu cap. cause
tempeste feu, sang tranche. »
Vers la fin de sa vie,
Nostradamus commence
à souffrir d'hydropisie.
Une nuit de juillet 1566,
il appelle un ami à son chevet
et lui fait ses adieux.
Le lendemain matin,
on le retrouve mort.
Il avait 62 ans.
Aujourd'hui encore,
plus de quatre siècles plus tard,
on continue d'étudier
et d'interpréter ses prophéties.
Nostradamus vécu
cette période intermédiaire
entre le Moyen Âge
et l'époque contemporaine.
Une période
marquée par la souffrance,
les troubles et les
bouleversements de toutes sortes.
La divination était le
seul moyen d'expliquer le fossé
entre le chaos
régnant sur la Terre
et l'idéal céleste
d'ordre et d'harmonie.
Lorsqu'un homme du XVIᵉ siècle
observait le ciel nocturne,
ce qu'il voyait
n'était pas différent
de ce qu'on
peut voir aujourd'hui.
Mais tout était alors chargé
d'une signification bien différente.
À cette époque,
on considère la Terre
comme le centre de l'Univers.
Le Soleil, la Lune et les planètes
gravitent autour de cet univers
créé par Dieu
pour l'Homme,
qui occupe
une place centrale
dans l'ordre
suprême des choses.
La nature toute entière
est chargée de sens
et chaque créature se voit
attribuer un rôle bien défini
en vue de l'accomplissement
des desseins divins.
Au Royaume des cieux,
Dieu est tout puissant.
On croit alors
que les étoiles
symbolisent l'ordre
et l'harmonie voulus par Dieu.
Modèle que
l'Homme doit suivre.
Convaincus que leur
rôle est de construire
une société en accord
avec les desseins divins,
les Hommes ne se sentent
pas maîtres de leur existence,
libres d'organiser leur vie
comme ils le veulent.
En fait, ils croient que
le respect de la volonté divine
leur assurera
la paix et l'harmonie
et comblera
tous leurs besoins.
Les paysans
sont dans leurs champs.
Les rois
dans leurs châteaux.
Les planètes au-dessus
et Dieu au plus haut des cieux,
régnant sur l'univers.
Mais cet idéal
de paix et d'harmonie
est très éloigné
des réalités de l'époque.
Partout sévissent la guerre,
la famine, la pauvreté et le chaos.
Au XVIᵉ siècle,
on considère ces fléaux
comme des punitions
infligées par Dieu
à ceux
qui violent ses lois.
Tous ces
événements naturels
sont interprétés comme
des signes de la colère divine.
Les événements exceptionnels tels
que le passage des comètes,
les éclipses
et les catastrophes naturelles
sont interprétés comme
autant de messages prophétiques.
C'est Dieu qui
bouleverse l'ordre naturel
enjoignant ainsi
à l'Homme de le rétablir
sous peine d'avoir à subir
de graves représailles.
Traditionnellement,
l'un des signes les plus
fréquents de la colère divine
est la naissance
d'un animal mal formé.
À cette époque,
on parle beaucoup
d'un animal connu
sous le nom de moine-veau.
Il s'agit d'un veau
qui porte la tonsure,
ce qui le fait
ressembler à un moine.
On voit immédiatement
dans l'apparition de cette figure,
un avertissement.
Une invitation
à réformer l'Église.
Cette interprétation n'est
pas très éloignée de la vérité.
Car l'Église, qui est
supposée guider les gens
dans la voie du Seigneur
et se faire l'instrument
de la volonté divine,
est corrompue.
Les prêtres et les évêques
vivent dans la débauche
et en cette période
de pauvreté croissante,
ils s'enrichissent en
soutirant de l'argent aux pauvres
en échange du
pardon de leurs péchés.
Un impôt sur le salut,
en quelque sorte.
Beaucoup sont persuadés
que des événements
tels que
l'apparition du moine-veau
désignent l'Église
comme responsable
des désordres
de l'époque.
Un jour, un prêtre
Allemand, Martin Luther,
affiche sur la porte du château
de Wittemberg ses 95 thèses
dans lesquelles il s'en prend
au chef suprême de l'Église,
le pape lui-même.
Il est
immédiatement excommunié.
Les actions de Luther
marquent le début de la Réforme
qui, balayant
le christianisme médiéval,
va donner
naissance au protestantisme.
Bientôt Luther
engage contre l'Église
une âpre bataille
dans laquelle la prophétie
sera l'une de ses
armes les plus redoutables.
Dans sa
traduction de la Bible,
Luther détourne
une célèbre prophétie
pour attaquer
violemment le pape.
La prophétie en question
annonce l'arrivée de la
prostituée fameuse de Babylone,
assise sur
une bête à sept têtes.
Traditionnellement,
le dernier livre du
Nouveau Testament, l'Apocalypse,
est richement illustré.
Notamment de gravures
représentant la mort
de la prostituée de Babylone.
En septembre 1522,
lors de la première
publication de la Bible de Luther,
on y reconnaît
la prostituée de Babylone.
Elle porte la tiare,
principale attribut du pape.
Mais cela ne constitue
que le début des hostilités.
L'Église riposte
et attaque Luther
avec sa propre
interprétation tendancieuse
d'une prophétie biblique.
Cette prophétie annonce
l'arrivée d'un faux prophète,
un suppôt de Satan.
Des savants vont même
jusqu'à prévoir la date précise
de son arrivée.
La prophétie est limpide.
Le faux prophète,
d'après des calculs que
personne ne songe à contester,
serait né en 1483.
Date qui correspond bien sûr
à la date de naissance de Luther.
Dès que Luther
commence à semer
la pagaille au sein du clergé,
faisant figure de rebelle
aux yeux de Rome,
des écrivains italiens
au fait de ces prophéties
expliquent que
Luther n'est autre que
le faux prophète
dont on annonce l'arrivée.
L’Église publie
des caricatures
dans lesquelles Luther,
le faux prophète,
apparaît comme un instrument
entre les mains de Satan.
Les partisans de la Réforme
s'empressent d'effacer son nom.
Un ami de Luther
se serait alors rendu
chez la mère de ce dernier
pour lui demander
si elle était sûre de la
date de naissance de son fils.
S'il était né en 1483
et non en 1484, ajoute t-il,
au moins aurait-il pu
conjurer le mauvais sort.
Mais sa date de naissance
est le moindre des soucis de Luther.
Désormais, il n'est
plus opposé à la seule Église,
mais également aux
réformateurs les plus radicaux.
Ces derniers, convaincus
que le mal s'est emparé du monde,
ne veulent rien moins que
détruire la société qui les entoure.
Pour soutenir
leurs vues extrémistes,
ils se réfèrent
à la Bible elle-même
et plus particulièrement
à l'Apocalypse.
Le dernier livre
du Nouveau Testament
est en effet
le récit de la fin du monde.
Une fin
particulièrement violente.
C'est l'histoire
de la plus grande bataille
que l'on
puisse imaginer.
Un combat épique
entre les forces
du bien et les forces du mal.
La bataille d'Armageddon.
Écrite à une époque
où les chrétiens sont
persécutés par les Romains,
cette histoire annonce
la victoire finale de Dieu
et de ses serviteurs.
Alors, le Christ
ressuscitera et règnera ici-bas
sur le Royaume de Dieu
pendant 1000 ans.
Jusqu'au jour
du Jugement dernier.
Ce règne de 1000 ans
sur la Terre comme au Ciel
s'appelle le millénium.
Et la doctrine proclamant
la venue de l'Apocalypse,
le millénarisme.
Les chrétiens ont une vision
atroce de la fin du monde.
Ils font subir à leurs ennemis
non seulement les Romains,
mais aussi
tous les non-chrétiens,
de terribles châtiments.
IIs Ies jettent dans des
fosses remplies de soufre
et ils meurent brûlés.
Les chrétiens, quant à eux,
connaissent une fin plus douce.
Le jour du Jugement dernier,
leur corps sera transformé
et ils deviendront immortels.
Mais en attendant,
durant les 1000 ans qui
précèdent le Jugement dernier,
ils conservent une enveloppe
charnelle qui ne vieillit pas,
ce qui est somme
toute assez valorisant.
Paix et
harmonie sur la Terre.
La résurrection de Jésus
récompense
les fidèles d'avoir gardé la foi
malgré les persécutions
dont ils ont été victimes.
Ainsi s'achève
le dernier épisode
de cette grande fable
historique et morale.
Les bons peuvent prétendre
à une éternité de béatitude,
tandis que
leurs ennemis
sont condamnés à
subir le châtiment qu'ils méritent.
Chez le peuple chrétien
opprimé de l'ère Romaine,
cet épilogue
Ô combien idyllique
a dû éveiller
un immense écho.
Après la mort du Christ,
la petite secte juive
qu'est le christianisme
devient la religion
officielle de l'Empire romain,
puis s'étend
au monde occidental.
L'Église devient
une institution riche et puissante
qui ne voit aucune raison
d'abandonner son pouvoir
et ses biens terrestres
au jour
du Jugement dernier.
Elle commence à se
distancier du millénarisme.
L'Église possède
en effet de riches monastères,
jouit de
nombreux privilèges
et ses membres ne souhaitent
pas le moins du monde
renoncer à tout cela.
Ils font alors de l'Apocalypse
une sorte d'allégorie
et le jour du Jugement
dernier étant encore loin,
le clergé ne songe
qu'à étendre son règne
sans se
soucier de l'avenir
ni de ce qu'il se produira
1000 ans plus tard.
Mais les prophéties
annoncées par l'Apocalypse
sont suffisamment vagues
pour pouvoir s'appliquer
à chaque période
de chaos et de corruption.
L'Église romaine
rejette le millénarisme.
Les réformateurs
radicaux au XVIᵉ siècle,
voient dans
le désordre ambiant
le signe annonciateur
de la bataille de l'Apocalypse.
À la fin du Moyen Âge,
on croit que la fin
du monde est pour demain.
Cette période
est marquée
par de nombreuses
révoltes paysannes.
Et ces paysans revendiquent
des choses très simples.
Ils réclament le rétablissement
des droits dont on les a privés.
Ils réclament
de meilleures conditions de vie.
Bref, des choses qui
semblent tout à fait raisonnables.
En marge
de ces mouvements,
On voit apparaître
des prophètes.
Généralement
des hommes cultivés,
qui ne font
pas partie des pauvres
et qui prennent
la tête de petits groupes.
Des plus pauvres
parmi les pauvres.
Des exclus de la société.
Ces prophètes
vont organiser ces groupes
avec le but
d'aider Dieu à opérer
une transformation du monde.
En 1524, en Allemagne,
ces groupes de paysans
prennent les armes
contre les autorités
y compris
contre l'Église catholique.
Ils luttent pour obtenir
de meilleures conditions de vie.
Ces paysans
révoltés attirent l'attention
d'un prédicateur
autoproclamé,
Thomas Muntzer.
Muntzer appartient à la
frange radicale du protestantisme.
Millénariste extrémiste,
il croit qu'il faut combattre
les ennemis de Dieu par les armes
et préparer
le retour du Messie.
Sa cible principale
est l'Église catholique.
En fait, il considère
comme des ennemis
tous ceux qui contestent
son interprétation
des Saintes Écritures.
Muntzer voit dans la
révolte sanglante des paysans
la preuve
que l'Apocalypse approche.
Il réunit une
petite armée d'adeptes,
leur assure
que Dieu est avec eux
et les lance
à l'assaut du mal,
l'Église et l'État.
Il se définit lui même comme
le prophète de l'Apocalypse.
« Comme les pommes
pourries sont mûres.
Comme les élus
sont devenus cléments.
Le temps de la
moisson est proche
et Dieu m'a
appelé pour la récolte.
J'ai aiguisé ma faucille
et n'aspire qu'à la vérité.
Mes lèvres, ma peau,
mes mains, mes cheveux,
mon âme, mon corps,
maudissent les incrédules.
Ne vous apitoyez pas
sur la misère des impies.
Ils mendient
et gémissent comme des enfants.
Soyez sans pitié.
Ne laissez pas
retomber votre épée. »
Muntzer lance
ses troupes dans la bataille,
certain que les canons du mal
ne sauraient les atteindre.
Ses adeptes
sont rapidement massacrés.
Muntzer parvient à fuir,
mais il est rattrapé et décapité.
Pourtant, ce
détournement de la prophétie
à des fins
politiques radicales
ne prend pas fin
avec le XVIᵉ siècle.
En 1939,
une femme Allemande
tombe sur un
ouvrage de Nostradamus.
Ses quatrains
vieux de 400 ans
semblent dépeindre
avec une telle précision
la situation de son pays,
qu'elle montre
l'ouvrage à son mari.
Lequel n'est autre
que Joseph Goebbels,
le ministre
de la propagande de Hitler.
« En l'an bien
proche esloigné de Venus.
Les deux plus grands
de l'Asie et d'Afrique,
Du Rhyn et Hister
qu'on dira sont venus,
Cris, pleurs a Malte
et costé Ligustique. »
Goebbels, ravi
qu'un prophète aussi célèbre
ait prévu
l'avènement d'Hitler,
décide d'exploiter
au mieux cette prophétie.
On demande à des spécialistes
des sciences occultes
d'interpréter ses quatrains
de manière à ce qu'ils annoncent
la victoire
de l'Allemagne
et donnent
une légitimité historique
au troisième Reich.
Pour démoraliser
les soldats alliés,
Goebbels va jusqu'à envoyer
derrière les lignes ennemies
ces prédictions
revues et corrigées.
Si un prophète du XVIᵉ siècle
avait prédit le troisième Reich,
c'est que la vision hitlérienne
d'une Allemagne nouvelle et forte
s'inscrit dans
la logique de l'Histoire.
L'accession au pouvoir des nazis
ne serait pas un fait du hasard,
mais un
signe du destin.
Pourtant,
dans sa prophétie,
Nostradamus ne mentionne
pas le nom du chef nazi.
Dans le quatrain original,
on trouve le mot Hister
et non Hitler
comme on le dit souvent.
Or Hister est le nom que l'on
donnait à l'époque au Danube.
La prophétie a joué
un grand rôle dans l'Histoire
et elle constitue le fondement
de la plupart des religions.
Elle a inspiré les rois,
provoqué des guerres
et façonné les esprits.
Les réformateurs
politiques et religieux,
ainsi que les millénaristes
de toutes tendances
s'en sont servis
comme d'une arme
pour étendre
leur influence.
Si la prophétie ne répondait pas
à un besoin humain profond,
jamais elle n'aurait eu
une telle importance
dans l'Histoire
de l'humanité.
C'est dans
les périodes de chaos,
au sein des communautés
opprimées ou isolées,
que les prédicateurs font
le plus grand nombre d'adeptes.
Ce qui est rassurant,
c'est que si l'on parvient
à prévoir toutes
ces horribles catastrophes,
toutes ces
souffrances humaines,
cela signifie qu'elles sont
dans l'ordre des choses
et qu'elles ne sont pas
le fruit du hasard.
Si l'on peut
prédire l'avenir,
c'est que le destin de l'humanité,
aussi accidenté soit-il,
n'est pas totalement
hasardeux et sombre.
Les prophéties
donnent un sens à l'Histoire,
qu'elles transforment
en une saga épique et morale
à vocation universelle.
Chaque Homme,
chaque chose y a sa place
et y joue
un rôle défini.
Avec la fin
du XVIᵉ siècle,
la vision
médiévale du monde
et avec
elle, la prophétie,
est battue en brèche.
Pourtant, notre
conception de l'Homme
comme élément
central de l'Univers
et notre besoin de donner
un sens à l'Histoire, perdure.
La croyance en la prophétie
a sans doute décliné,
mais d'une
certaine manière,
elle n'a jamais
totalement disparue.
Si l'Histoire est un récit,
alors elle doit avoir une fin.
À l'approche
de l'an 2000,
la prophétie
connaît un regain d'intérêt.
La seule prophétie
que Nostradamus
ait jamais datée précisément
est sur le point
de se réaliser.
« L'an mil neuf cens
nonante neuf sept mois,
Du ciel viendra
un grand Roy d'effrayeur:
Resusciter le
grand Roy d'Angolmois,
Avant après Mars
régner par bon heur. »
Au septième
mois de l'année 1999,
viendra du ciel
un grand chef effrayant
pour faire revivre le grand
conquérant de l'Angoumois,
avant et après la guerre
règnera au maximum.
Mais cette prophétie
de Nostradamus
n'annonce pas
la fin du monde.
En effet, ses prophéties
englobent les 1000 ans à venir
et même au-delà.
L'avenir sera
toujours incertain
et les prophéties
ne sont pas près de disparaître.